The significance of this area for me, as a
child I was brought up out here with my family,
we'd come out in the seasonal periods and
live on the river and the estuary, gathering
mahinga kai.
Most people are unaware we have a lot of rare
birds out here and not only rare, they're
in decline.
There is roughly seventy bird species recorded
in and around the estuary here.
There are about twelve endemic species that
can be seen here.
For us it is important that it is protected.
So the bylaw has just been changed for the
estuary and this area, to a no-dog zone.
Also we've put into place for no vehicle access
into the estuary.
We patrol weekendly, and weekly to just try
and combat against anyone who's not up to
date with the change in the bylaw for vehicles
in the estuary.
Yeah, I think for a lot of them it is just
education.
They don't perhaps realise what damage they're
doing.
It's like everywhere you go, 99% of the public
are really good, it's just that 1% that are
out there to be disruptive, and that's where
the local community jump on board with the
new bylaw.
They've all had a part, their input, through
the process of the bylaw being put into place,
so when they see something happening in their
area, their patch, they'll give us a call
and we'll come down and deal with the situation.